I am a 38 year old man.
Yeah.
Should I watch Lizzie McGuire? And if so, why?
What am I going to get out of it?
I'll field this one.
Absolutely Brian. You should sit down right now.
You should. Let a man talk about it, that's right.
Please mansplain it
Let a man talk about it.
That's right, please. Man.
Give me a moment.
Nina, can you tell us about some hidden gems on
Disney+ that you think everyone should watch?
I sure can. Brian, so as a child of the
nineties and early 2000s, I did watch a
lot of Disney channel original content. I was
definitely the market for many of their shows
and when Disney+ first released, rather than
going to the Marvel catalog, rather than
reliving the great animated classics of Disney, I
went directly for Lizzie McGuire without stopping.
I did not pass go. I did not collect $200. I
went directly for Lizzie Maguire because that's a
show that I grew up on and I wanted to be her and
something I probably shouldn't admit on looper.com
is that instead of seeing the first X-Men
movie, I saw the Lizzie McGuire movie instead.
If that's a fireable offense, I'll take it.
I don't care.
But yeah. So for the uninitiated, Lizzie McGuire
was the first outing of Hillary Duff who is still
acting still doing pretty well. She just finished
a I believe seven season run on Younger, which was
a pretty decent TV show created by Darren Star
who created Sex in the City and Emily in Paris.
Did not know that.
Yep. She was the co-lead alongside Sutton
Foster and Molly Bernard and Peter Herman
and several other, very, very talented people.
So yeah, Lizzie McGuire was her first foray
into acting. I think she was like picked
from relative obscurity to play the part.
And it's your average teenage girl show, but it
has the twist of her having a cartoon version
of herself who looks just nothing like
her at all. Like not the same haircut,
facial likeness is really off, but you're just
like, okay, that's Lizzie's brain, that's fine.
And it just acts out like the day-to-day
stuff. And the first episode I returned to is
the infamous one where Lizzie wants her first bra
and screams I want a bra very loudly. And then it
turns into slow motion. It's a masterpiece,
should have won several Oscars that year.
Emmy's I think you mean.
She gets her own TV show when she
does that, but when I do it...
I meant Oscars.
Okay. Sorry.
I'm taking this one step further. So it's a
really, like I went back and I tried to watch
some of it and it's very of its time,
especially for girls. You're like, oh,
I would definitely own all those like really
ugly low-rise jeans and butterfly clips and
glittery t-shirts. And the way it's shot is really
jarring. There's way too much slow motion. There's
slow motion in like every single episode,
like five to six times in like 25 minutes.
Now, can I interrupt you for a second?
You absolutely can I'm really
just talking about Lizzie McGuire.
That's my question, right? You and
I, there is an age gap between us.
Yes.
I am a 38 year old man.
Yeah.
Should I watch Lizzie McGuire? And if so, why?
I'll field this one. Absolutely
Brian. You should sit down...
You should. Let a man talk about it. That's right.
Please mansplain this.
Nina, give me a moment. Brian...
Start a new Twitter account. Call
it Brian watches Lizzie McGuire.
Honestly.
Bathe in the adoration of a
thousand people that you did not
hope existed. I think you're
going to do very well with this.
In all seriousness.
In all seriousness you should watch it because
Hillary Duff is still acting and it's nice
to see where her roots came from especially
if you're planning on watching How I Met Your
Father which just recently started filming.
That's right.
But I have a chaser for you that pairs perfectly
with Lizzie McGuire and it's a Disney channel
original movie called Cadet Kelly, which
is kind of a spinoff of Private Benjamin,
where a girly girl goes to military school. And
the reason you should watch that is because in
the years since its release, it has become
like a favorite among the LGBTQ community
because the sexual tension between Hillary
Duff and Christie Carlson Romano is palpable.
Oh.
So it remains relevant today because
you could really read it as a young
girl discovering who she is in a military
academy with a lot of ribbon dancing.
Nina...
I'm not sure that you...
I'm going to stand by this.
... quite convinced me, but I am more intrigued
than I was before we started this conversation.
I knew that I knew you'd at least be intrigued.
I didn't think I'd get to convince. That's fine.
I've done what I came here to do.
That's fair, Tom, do you...
If you don't want to watch ribbon
dancing I just can't help you.
I mean, I do want to watch ribbon dancing.
I think we all want to watch ribbon dancing.
Yeah. Yeah.
Have you not read his Twitter account?
Brian watches ribbon dancing. It is...
No I must have missed that one.
Nina, Lizzie McGuire, and you'll
forgive me because I was the right age,
but I guess just not the right demographic
to ever really see that kind of thing...
Sure, definitely not the right demographic.
How does the having a cartoon version
of herself with body dysmorphia? Like
how does that affect the plot
or what does that do for her?
It basically serves the place of narration.
So instead of her talking over every scene,
it's like, this is what her brain is doing.
Okay.
And it's full of hi-jinks in there.
Sounds like a Herman's Head situation. Anyone?
Kind of. It's a little...
Remember that, Herman's Head.
Absolutely.
You know what, Lizzie McGuire is the Being
John Malcovich of the Disney channel.
Okay. All right. You know what? Now I'm sold.
I didn't think of that earlier I thought
of it just now. And I stand by it.
I will be watching Lizzie McGuire tonight.
I knew it.
Okay, you got me.
You got us to watch Bluey the other day, so.
Speaking of which... My pick for hidden
gems on Disney+ that you should watch.
I have two picks. One of them is bluey.
Now I am a parent of a two year old who
loves the Bluey theme song and
tolerates the show that follows it.
But so this is a show about a family of blue...
Two of them are blue dogs. Two of them are,
I guess, orange or brown. They're a
family of dogs. They live in Australia.
They are otherwise normal human
beings, except they are dogs.
They walk on two feet, right?
They walk on two legs...
Yeah. Or two legs rather.
And they do all the things that
suburban Australianites do...
Australians, I guess I should say.
Australianites...
Australianites is not a thing. Yeah.
Not the preferred term.
It's the only weakness of Australia, man.
Australianite. No. So this show it's about this
little kid Bluey and her little sister Bingo.
And they go on advent... They don't even
go on adventurous. They just exist and do
things that little children do, and their parents
do things with them. And it's adorable. And it's
also genuinely funny. Like it's a really well-made
show. Each episode is about eight minutes long.
And even if you don't have, if you have
kids, you should watch it with your kids.
If you don't have kids, you should still watch
it because it's genuinely entertaining. It has
made me laugh out loud several times.
It's just really, really well done. And
I like it a lot. It's good stuff. It's good
television. So, anyway, that was one pick.
The other pick...
That was pick one.
That was pick one. The other one
is similarly, somewhat out of left
field. It's just called Mickey Mouse...
Never heard of it.
And they're short cartoons.
Now, okay. So here's the thing.
Who's the Mickey mouse.
Shut up.
You're going to have to start at the beginning.
Just give us like a...
So Mickey mouse obviously is one of the most
well-known characters in the entire world.
It is the Disney mascot. I'll say this too,
for the first 38 years of my life. I have
always thought that Mickey Mouse sucks a lot.
Like Mickey Mouse sucks. Like if you're given the
choice between watching a Mickey Mouse cartoon,
or a Bugs Bunny cartoon, you watched Bugs
Bunny. That's just what you basically...
Obviously.
Bugs Bunny is fun and cool and crafty and he likes
to do violence on people. And it's wonderful.
Mickey Mouse by contrast is lame
and boring. And he just sucks.
Agree.
However, there are a series of shorts
that were made probably within the last
seven or eight years that are all on Disney+,
they're like three to five minutes long each
and they're deranged. They're so funny.
They're so good. Mickey Mouse and Donald
Duck and Goofy and Minnie Mouse and everyone,
they're all doing these strange adventures.
And they're just crazy. There's one episode
where Mickey, he's going to order a new
fish tank for his beloved fish and a cat comes
in and breaks the tank and then things happen.
And at one point the fish is pan fried. At
one point, the fish is devoured by the cat.
The fish is dying. It's very funny. I'm not
selling it now, but I guarantee that if you watch
the first couple ones and you don't laugh, there's
something wrong with you. They are so funny.
Well you're painting a really
grim picture of it. So...
Well that's the point.
We're going to need to check it out.
The grimness is the point. That's the whole
thing. It's not your grandad's Mickey Mouse.
It's the Zack Synder cut of Mickey Mouse.
Snyder cut of Mickey Mouse...
It's all in four by three.
All I can say is that...
Goofy says the F word.
Those are my picks, Bluey, a show
for children and Mickey Mouse shorts
also for children. I'm almost
40. Tom, what's a hidden gem...
You're not too old for Mickey
Mouse shorts. I think they're...
On Disney+.
I wear them every weekend.
Yeah.
Yes, there it is. Tom. What's a Disney+
hidden gem that we should watch.
I've prepared a statement.
Oh no.
I'm so nervous about whatever is coming.
Please let me finish.
If you and your pups are looking for an hour and
29 minutes of great A family fun look no further
than Beverly Hills Chihuahua 3 Viva LA Fiesta.
In this fun for the whole family, adventure,
Poppy, Chloe, and their litter of pups trade their
So-Cal set up for life at a swanky high-end hotel,
but when the littlest pup Rosa doesn't feel quite
at home after being bullied by a larger dog...
They're coming for you.
But when their littlest pup, Rosa doesn't feel
quite at home after being bullied by a larger dog,
it's up to the whole posse of lovable mutts
to throw her a quince that she'll never forget
featuring the voices of George Lopez, Jake Busey,
and the Osmond kid that isn't Haley Joel, Beverly
Hills Chihuahua 3 Viva LA Fiesta is a pup lifting
story. So good you'll never want to press paws.
Brian Orndorff of BluRay.com said that of
the film, "Parents won't feel battered by
relentless stupidity," Sandy Angelo
Chen of Common Sense media called it
"Entertaining talking dog threequal," In
a six out of 10 star review James Plath
of Moving Metropolis gushed, "If you liked
Beverly Hills Chihuahua, you'll like the second
sequel more than the first. It felt like the
filmmakers just tried harder this time around."
Cool.
The fuzzy fun doesn't stop in sunny California,
for even more cuddly excitement, checkout 2013's
Super Buddies, the seventh and final installment
in the Air Buddies franchise sees America's
favorite cadre of huggable golden retrievers
gifted with abilities beyond the scope of
mortal understanding thanks to a collection of
mystical rings from the planet Inspiron. Taking
new personas as superheroes the buddys learn
that with great pawer comes great respawnsibility
featuring the voices of kid favorites,
John Ratzenberger and Tim Conway,
as well as John Michael Higgins, Colin Hanks
and Zendaya it's positively outstanding.
Cool.
Is that it?
Looking for something a little
more... Yeah, that's it.
Thanks for watching. Please hit like and
subscribe. So you don't miss a single episode.